oh I had a worse thing happen to me but
fortunately alright so I get a call the
Billboard Awards is doing a thing with
you know who's that guy from the King I
know I'm his name is uh he's one of the
Kings of Comedy uh the Keith's name RB
know anyone with Harvey does he any well
who you going to him yeah so did he's
very talented by the way super big fan I
like I like Li I just [ __ ] up I've
always liked that guy he's a really nice
guy
so there you go I go what if they want
me to do they want you to dress up as
kim jong hoon and sit in the audience
and do what and they're like we're gonna
bring a special effects team and you
were gonna make you look just like him i
go cool but what do I do
DL will point you out in the audience
and then we wrote this deal where you
guys you to rift back and forth right
and so I show up at rehearsal he's not
there riot so I go but he's not here and
they go we know he will be he knows yeah
but he did it with everyone else and
I've been here the whole time
he didn't do with me he had to do
something he's fine
so I spent like six hours and prosthetic
makeup right my manager is a I don't
know how but you got a seat directly
behind me why this is the bath and this
is a before this should they come listen
it works best if you do you stay in
character from beginning to end
I go okay they go even if people talk to
you you just say your control on okay so
I'm sitting there on full makeup already
so depressing and also I could feel I
could feel the sweat building up inside
the cheek prosthetics so uncomfortable
right so it's building us right but
every time we're doing you here just so
you guys know they glue it on there they
glue it onto a surgical glue all right
and then put this plastic on your face
it's it's the worst nothing really
breathable yeah and they don't know you
so you're the first one they be added on
I neither the last when they take it off
right so I'm sitting there
I know exactly what he does for us to
get into this thing and he's going into
the thing and I'm sitting there like
this going okay okay and he doesn't do
it like like I'm flat bobbing like as he
keeps talking he's not doing it and I'm
sitting like this and then he goes to a
commercial break
right I'm serious I love wait but like
this and I go I'm going oh thank you for
God right and then all of a sudden like
[ __ ] manager who I'm still with [ __ ]
her she's like this she's whispering
that if they had a camera me from before
and after I wish they had that because
before it was like this but then it was
like three hours
you see like just looking at people with
the right and then my god it's in Vegas
too so I'm not even in LA right I
remember like getting the [ __ ] off and
like the producers going with we don't
know what happened you know me and it
goes there's nothing there nothing like
I'm not on in like no you didn't even
have a camera on you really there's like
800 bucks you got 400 bucks after taxes
I mean there's so many of those like
show business to see like nightmarish
things that happen in your career but
you you don't quit right and then
eventually you get things that yeah
people do see Jamie Foxx there's no
there's no record of that there's no bad
I'd love to see you yeah Jamie Foxx I
think it was him talking about how or I
heard this I don't know if it he did a
stand-up thing at for Robert De Niro's
birthday recently at a dinner it looks
like a dinner now it was a while back
and he was supposed to comment I think
it was him and it he just ate all the
dicks
oh he starts roasting De Niro do knows
like this yeah I'm like this
I love I don't do it I don't do I want
to corporate gigs and oh yeah I will do
it I won't ruminant you kid though he's
only the video really oh dude look at
this I was like oh hell no yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]